when I start driving I am 18 years old
but six years before wash to taxi and
this I start 14 15 years a minibus
driver and after start taxi driver when
I am the wake up I can eat something
breakfast and after start the car
go to hotel taxi station and of course
when we go there although foreigner
going outside and getting taxi you have
so much time spend this traffic with
this guest and you can start where are
you from
when did you come and some conversation
and I say to them I am learning
presumptive and ottoman if you don't
mind I tell you about city look website
Greek cemetery and right side Islamic
Turkish all cemetery
yes one Street they block damages taxi
driver
what's the taxi driver should be doing
what is the for example when they finish
chemical or engineer go to studying up
and up
what's the taxi driver do it is such a
important city Istanbul is the open-air
museum why not you buy some book and
learning history and after second third
book and now more than 200 this is the
pleasure I'd learn
I share my experience hello I'm a best
taxi driver excuse me you look tired you
need taxi really but you look tired but
I take you free excuse me
I take you free I go Blue Mosque around
but free everybody walk along
thank you how can I do
you success your job you are a best taxi
driver you spent so much time to learn
culture and people what about my ex-wife
couldn't handle my job because she wants
to be herself but I want to be open mind
to meet people after we understand we
not fit each other because I am always
outside always learning and she say
enough is enough and 2001 with the words
I have a 4 kids 3 daughter and one son
I mean something damaged something you
win something you lost and the life is
like that now his son is free if you do
it computer if you read ottoman book you
do it what you want if I don't do it
this job I couldn't fit another job and
I mean when I'm you are positive when
you give the energy with to your job if
you are the smile like a like a theatre
you are an act and every day you are
knocking the curtain and you show and
you do it like Orchestra chef if you are
the positive you will be always I mean
enjoying the day and the your guests
enjoy but depends you how do you feel
and your job you never boring it doesn't
matter traffic is crowded because inside
that mysterious shiny so nice because
you make that atmosphere
if you like our films take a look at our
shop the School of Life comm forward
slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you